einer der die demonstrationen weniger
nachvollziehen kann ist johannes
lohmeyer erst chef der dresdner
tourismusverbandes und hotelier seine
branche leidet extrem unter den corona
maßnahmen
herr lohmeyer schön dass sie sich heute
morgen zeit genommen haben ja was geht
ihnen durch den kopf wenn sie die bilder
dieser demonstrationen sehen wo die
menschen ohne mundschutz mit mundschutz
zwar sind aber ohne sicherheitsabstand
hinterlässt das ehrlich das sprachlos
ganze branchen werden derzeit noch am
arbeiten gehindert unternahm die
veranstaltungsbranche aber auch wir
arbeiten unter extremer auflagen die uns
ein wirtschaftliches arbeiten unmöglich
machen und dort feuern mal eben so
15.000 leute eine corona party auf
offener straße also das hat mich
wirklich sprachlos gemacht und darf
unter aufsicht der stadt macht das ist
wirklich um gehörte schon jetzt muss man
natürlich sagen gegen rassismus auf die
straße zu gehen ist ja an sich etwas
gutes das ist ja für die gute sache
trotzdem was fordern sie jetzt konkret
wenn sie das alles sehen also vor
wenigen wochen sind noch die menschen
für bürgerliche freiheitsrechte in
berlin auf die straße gegangen und da
ist unter anderem eine bürgerrechtlerin
von der polizei weggeschleppt worden
also wenn wir jetzt in deutschland
anfangen zwischen guten und schlechten
demonstrationen zu unterscheiden
dann muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ist der
rechtsstaat schon besser aus als wir uns
das jedem träumen lassen
wie sieht es denn derzeit bei ihnen in
der branche aus was ist der eindruck
richtig katastrophal aus also wir
hangeln herrn vielen standorten der zeit
zwischen belegungen zwischen 10 und 15
prozent
sehr viele hotels den nach wie vor
geschlossen die hotels die geöffnet
haben können allesamt nicht
wirtschaftlich arbeiten weil es enorme
auflagen gibt mit abständen man darf
keinen frühstücksbuffet anbieten wo die
leute nicht mindestens drei meter
auseinander stehen und vor allem vor dem
hintergrund all dieser auflagen und
hinter alten arbeitsplatz vernichtenden
einschränkungen muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen wer wird mit zweierlei maß
gemessen